[Música]
en el extremo sur de la Península
Ibérica enclavado en plena provincia
española de Cádiz y rodeado de una de
las zonas económicas y socialmente más
deprimida de toda Europa se encuentra
Gibraltar para los que nos estáis viendo
desde España este territorio británico
de ultramar no necesita presentación
cada dos por tres por un motivo u otro
para grandes espacios en los medios de
comunicación y en algunos casos por los
días tan marcianas cómo está
petición de 10 años de cárcel por robar
un bloque de hormigón
en sus órdenes de detención vive del
delito
[Música]
eres un territorio británico de ultramar
cuya soberanía fue entregada por los
españoles a los británicos mediante el
conocido Tratado de Utrecht en 1713 como
parte del acuerdo de paz tras la Guerra
de Sucesión española que llevo a los
Borbones al poder
ahora bien porque la política hablamos
de un recóndito diminuto y aparentemente
intrascendente lugar a quién le importa
realmente Gibraltar pues queridos amigos
amigas y si os digo que el pene se ha
convertido en uno de los territorios más
prósperos y ricos de todo el mundo
atentos
[Música]
españa considera Gibraltar como la
última colonia británica en territorio
europeo como España siempre ha hecho
desde esta tribuna no puedo dejar de
recordar que Gibraltar es la única
colonia existente en el territorio
europeo
sin embargo siendo justos esta es una
definición que tiene más agujeros que un
queso gruyere por ejemplo el Ejecutivo
gibraltareño está actualmente liderado
por este hombre el ministro principal
Fabián Picardo un hombre que encabeza un
gobierno el de Gibraltar que disfrutar
de un grado de independencia y
autogobierno prácticamente total en lo
que respecta al territorio e incluso
poder desarrollar
[Música]
lo veis por mucho que tantos y tantos
políticos españoles se empeña en
hablarme colonia la realidad pues parece
muy distinta con todo y a pesar de su
escasa población el tema Gibraltar
volvió a copar todas las portadas y
debate político en la España del 2016
porque pues atentos
más cerca de Gibraltar José Manuel
García
qué futuro le aguarda Gibraltar de qué
demonios vive exactamente el Peñón y ojo
porque creo que la respuesta es para
sorprender queridos amigos amigas como
decía antes Gibraltar se ha convertido
en uno de los lugares más prósperos de
todo el mundo atento
[Música]
queridos amigos y amigas de
visualpolitik Gibraltar se ha convertido
en un territorio tremendamente próspero
y qué queréis que os diga eso eso es
algo que se nota
una diferencia abismal respecto a la
situación socioeconómica del territorio
español que lo rodea es prácticamente
cómo pasar de la noche a la mañana
mientras que entrar en Gibraltar supone
darse de bruces con torres y
organizaciones de lujo en construcción
coches de alta gama negocios en auge y
una tasa de desempleo de menos del 1 %
la situación al otro lado de la frontera
es completamente distinta ahí está por
ejemplo el caso de La Línea de la
Concepción fijaos
[Música]
La Línea de la Concepción la ciudad
española que hace frontera con Gibraltar
parece una situación económica y social
muy complicada de hecho protagonista
habitual de los realities televisivos
enfocados a cuestiones de crímenes
marginalidad y narcóticos con alrededor
de un 70% de desempleo juvenil en
algunos barrios deprimidos la ciudad y
toda su comarca circundante el Campo de
Gibraltar son pastor del narcotráfico y
la inseguridad se calcula que más de
3000 personas participan del tráfico de
estupefacientes que llegan desde África
junto a ello el contrabando de alcohol
tabaco y las ayudas públicas son algunas
de las principales actividades del
entorno
evidentemente las diferencias pues se
notan por los cuatro costados queréis
algunos ejemplos pues fijados mientras
que en la línea el salario medio apenas
supera los 17000 € anuales apenas a unos
pocos cientos de metros de distancia de
Gibraltar este salario promedio se
multiplica por más de 2 hasta superar
los 36000 € y ojo porque si utilizamos
otras estadísticas como la inversión la
productividad las diferencias son aún
mucho mayores de hecho basta con que
echemos un vistazo a la producción
económica de territorios para entender
de que estamos hablando exactamente
[Música]
pues bien para que os hagáis una idea a
pesar de sus 34000 habitantes y de su
ridícula dimensión espera que el PIB es
súper pronto los 3500 millones de
dólares una cifra que ya había sido
antes de la pandemia hablamos amigos de
un PIB per cápita de unos 100000 $ es
decir que mientras se está convirtiendo
en uno de los territorios más prósperos
de todo Europa e incluso de todo el
mundo con una tasa de crecimiento real
medio de casi el 7% anual durante los 10
años previos al coronavirus la zona
española que lo rodea Sport contra una
de las áreas más deprimidas de la Unión
Europea ahora bien la pregunta que
podemos hacernos
el puerto las finanzas el turismo y tal
vez por encima de todo el juego en línea
altares de los principales puertos del
mar Mediterráneo para el reportaje del
combustible el conocido como bunkering
que constituye entre el 85 y el 90% de
la actividad total del puerto su
liderazgo en esta materia se explica en
buena medida gracias a que el reportaje
de barcos mercantes en Gibraltar está
libre de impuestos la segunda gran
actividad de Gibraltar son las finanzas
y los seguros una industria que el
gobierno local lleva años promoviendo
tanto es así que a pesar de ser un sitio
tan pequeño cuenta con alrededor de 20
bancos internacionales con sede o
sucursal dónde se dedican casi en
exclusiva a la gestión de activos
financieros absorbo Gibraltar no es un
paraíso fiscal pero si ha puesto sobre
la mesa una regulación ágil e impuestos
moderados por ejemplo no graba las
ganancias de capital y fue una de las
primeras jurisdicciones de todo el
planeta en crear un marco regulatorio
adaptado a las Fintech otro ejemplo su
relativamente reducido impuesto sobre
los beneficios empresariales actualmente
del 12,5% que ha contribuido a quien
muchas empresas establezcan su ser en
este lugar hasta el punto de que hay
unas 20000 empresas en pequeño
territorio de 34000 habitantes
luego el turismo pues es otro de los
grandes atractivos de este lugar
cada año entre 11 y 12 millones de
turistas y visitantes llegan hoy lo que
supone una de las tasas de turistas en
relación a los residentes más altas de
todo el mundo y no no es algo casual
además de sus peculiaridades y hasta
ahora ausencia de impuestos indirectos
[Música]
y es que veréis desde que en 2005 el
gobierno del Peñón sacar adelante una
nueva Ley del Juego esta industria se ha
disparado hasta el punto que algunas de
las principales empresas de juego online
de todo el mundo que están instaladas
justo aquí en el Peñón estoy hablando de
empresas como William Hill otro
amigo se ha convertido en un enorme
mundial del juego online ahora bien por
qué porque estás empezando escogido
exactamente este recóndito lugar pues en
otras cosas porque este lugar tienda de
las regulaciones más avanzadas de juego
electrónico de todo el mundo una
comisión regulatoria que trabajar con
los tiempos al fin y al cabo es que se
la juegan todo a ser competitivos y un
bajo nivel de impuestos solo juego
queridos amigos amigas tal y como hemos
visto en otras ocasiones una de las
grandes ventajas que tienen estas micro
jurisdicciones es que tanto las
autoridades como la propia población
tienen muchos incentivos a explotar sus
ventajas competitivas hasta tal punto
que habitualmente se comportan casi como
empresas con una misión adaptarse los
tiempos lo más rápidamente posible y
maximizar la creación de actividad
económica y ese es precisamente el caso
del Peñón de Gibraltar
tendrá muchas cosas criticables pero
constantemente
no puedo
a pesar de lo que muchos creen lo cierto
es que por ahora el brexit de Gibraltar
salvo por la sustitución de la bandera
europea por la de la Commonwealth pues
no se ha notado demasiado y esto ha sido
así porque las condiciones de salida del
Reino Unido de la Unión Europea no se
aplicaban a Gibraltar cuya situación
acordó negociarse por separado y
precisamente para evitar un brexit duro
que hubiera supuesto muchas trabas tanto
para el peñón como para no es
trabajadores y proveedores españoles que
viven de teclado británico que los
gobiernos de las tres partes implicadas
España Reino Unido y Gibraltar
impulsaron llamado acuerdo de Nochevieja
un acuerdo político qué tal y como
podréis imaginar por su nombre sucedió
in extremis un 31 de diciembre 2020 y
que fija un periodo transitorio de 4
años con medidas especiales para
Gibraltar
o una frontera externa de la Unión
Europea
[Música]
el acuerdo de Nochevieja cambiará por
completo la situación del Peñón con su
entorno el acuerdo establece la libre
circulación de personas y mercancías lo
que supone incorporar a Gibraltar por
primera vez al espacio Schengen esto
conlleva la desaparición de la verja el
paso Adanero y los controles que había
en la frontera entre España y el
territorio británico
en Gibraltar
es decir que aunque siga estando bajo
soberanía británica el peñón quedará más
unido que nunca la política comunitaria
por supuesto las elecciones están
garantizadas
[Música]
cines más lejos el 20 de julio de 2021
la Comisión Europea presento el borrador
que sentará las bases de la negociación
de la relación futura entre ambas partes
una vez pasado el periodo transitorio de
4 años entre otras cosas este borrado al
contemplar que el control de las
fronteras dejará de estar en manos del
Frontex para quedar directamente bajo
control de las autoridades españolas y
sus cuerpos de seguridad lo que no tardo
en hacer estallar la furia
con la Unión Europea sobre el brexit
es más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima fiesta de
aquí no estamos hablando de soberanía
tenemos una postura irrenunciable en lo
relativo a la soberanía